[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro de VIP
aujourd'hui j'ai le très grand plaisir
d'être en présence d'un écrivain
prolifique Gérard de cortance c'est même
la troisième fois qu'il a la gentillesse
de nous rendre visite Charles de
cortance bonjour Oui troisième fois
voilà vous avez eu donc une première
vous avez fait une première visite pour
une interview on était en 2021 et vous
aviez sorti un livre qui s'appelle
l'homme qui veut été voir la mer
c'était le roi le titre
voilà un livre incroyable qui donnait un
livret mouvant qui donnait une autre
image de Louis XVI et qui était eu un
grand succès d'ailleurs pas très efforme
de réhabilitation de Louis XV on est
d'accord voilà c'était très chouette et
après je vous ai revu nous nous sommes
revus pour Frédéric Gallo votre meilleur
ami vous l'aimez beaucoup vous lui avez
consacré beaucoup de ouvrages
pareil et là aujourd'hui elle on change
complètement de d'univers de de temps
d'époque et nous voilà partis alors au
fin fond du Moyen-Âge au début du
moyen-âge on est en 1100 et quelques et
vous nous parlez d'une jeune fille en
feu qui s'appelle
Christine
oui alors mais c'est pas
oui et non en fait c'est une simple
locale
ne l'a pas reconnu
malgré mais il y a beaucoup de de
Saintes et de saints qui sont dans cette
situation mais c'est évident que c'est
une sainte mon accord très toute sa vie
le
démontera mais c'est une sainte rebelle
mais oui oui bien sûr alors du coup
cette jeune femme vous pouvez nous
raconter juste un peu le début de
l'histoire elle a elle a 15 ans elle a
15 ans on est en 165 donc c'est la
charnière 12e 13e siècle c'est très
important c'est ce qu'on appelle le
moyen-âge central alors pour situer un
petit peu c'est un
énorme changement à l'époque c'est à
dire que l'Église se développe
énormément
on construit les abbayes
on crée des pèlerinages mais pour créer
des pèlerinages il faut des seins
parce que les saints vont donner des
reliques mais avant qu'un saint existe
on écrit c'est d'éviter c'est-à-dire des
agiographies du sein donc le point de
départ du livre en fait c'est la vie de
cette de cette jeune femme qui va être
racontée par par un moine alors
il y a deux choses la première c'est que
effectivement il y a eu une vie de cette
scène qui était racontée par de Quentin
près qui est un moine érudit qui fait 30
pages en latin c'est pas beaucoup et
c'est évident que pour être reconnu
comme saint ou sainte il faut rentrer
dans certains canons certains certains
critères
l'idée que j'avais c'était de raconter
la vraie vie de cette sainte parce que
la vraie vie de cette sainte évidemment
si on la connaît vraiment
elle ne va pas être sainte parce que
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui fait des
choses absolument y recevoir pour
l'église de l'époque
alors ça se passe dans un petit village
à Saint-Trond
orpheline elle a deux soeurs elle garde
le troupeau
on l'aime beaucoup les jolies les
simples
elles se promène seul dans la forêt dans
le dans ce petit ce petit village
liégeois un jour elle meurt tout le
monde est triste bien entendu bon au
fond elle était si belle
c'était pas encore une sainte mais enfin
on sentait qu'il y avait un appel divin
enfin quelque chose comme ça et
au moment de de
l'enterrement dans l'église il y a une
résurrection
et le monde dans les dans les cintres et
là évidemment c'est une sorte de de
cataclysme total
et quand elle explique ce qui s'est
passé
à ses sœurs et au prêtre qui est là qui
est un qui est un prêtre comment dire de
village
il est brave il est complètement dépassé
par parce qu'il se passe et il est
d'autant plus dépassé qu'il lui raconte
la chose suivante
il y a une résurrection ce qu'on
appellerait aujourd'hui Noémie
il y a quelque chose de l'expérience de
la mort de mort imminente de retour
c'est il y a une description qui
correspond tout à fait d'ailleurs alors
le retour elle a choisi et c'est là où
c'est comment dire c'est là là la
première rébellion en quelque sorte qui
va pas du tout être acceptée par par
l'église de l'époque c'est elle revient
parce que on lui a confié une mission et
la mission c'est d'expliquer aux hommes
contre le purgatoire contre le l'enfer
et le paradis il y a une troisième
dimension parce que et ces 3ème
dimension c'est le purgatoire alors et
c'est pour ça que je citais l'époque
12e 13e siècle à cette époque le
purgatoire n'est pas du tout dans le
noble catholique alors c'est ça on en
parlait pas avant on commence à en
parler mais ça va mettre 100 ans
à ce qu'on y croit vraiment est-ce qu'on
se dit voilà il y a une troisième
dimension qui permet
aux
morts qui ne peuvent pas rentrer
directement au Paradis d'attendre
d'expier d'expier de ne pas aller en
enfer selon les péchés qu'ils ont obtenu
mais c'est complètement
iconoclaste à l'époque ça n'arrange
personne cette histoire du pluriel
les gens que elle est chargée comment
dire de faire le lien entre les vivants
et les morts et c'est pour ça que je
parle je dis que l'époque est importante
parce qu'il y a une forme de réalisme
magique à l'époque
et au fond il y a cette croyance qu'on
peut dialoguer avec les morts que les
revenants donc viennent sur terre
dialogues avec les vivants oui mais
comment il y a rien de négatif là-dedans
c'est-à-dire ça fait partie de la vie
quotidienne et elle est chargée de faire
ce lien entre entre les vivants et les
morts il y a un côté psychopompe ce
qu'on appellerait
il y a quelque chose de canal entre les
défunts et les vivants si vous voulez
alors il y a deux il y a deux actions
chez comment dire chez Christine
admirable il y a une action autour de du
divin autour de l'église catholique
et il y a une deuxième action qui est
une action plus séculière dans le siècle
et qui est comment dire le
l'intervention dans la vie quotidienne
des gens et c'est là où ça va poser un
vrai vrai problème pour les autorités
religieuses pour le pour les autorités
laïques
c'est qu'en fait il y a pas d'autres
termes elle fout un bordel incroyable
dans la région de Liège mais ça va
s’étendre et pourquoi parce qu'elle veut
au fond on pourrait dire que c'est une
féministe avant la lettre ça
revendications
sont absolument hallucinantes
c'est-à-dire qu'on les prend les unes
après les autres et on s'aperçoit
qu'elle pourrait être valable encore
aujourd'hui il y a une chose il y a une
chose il y a une sorte de de
modernité dans ce qu'elle dans ce qu'est
le propose qui est absolument
hallucinante et c'est ça qui m'a fasciné
dans le dans le personnage
par exemple elle ce qui est inacceptable
pour une catholique à l'époque elle est
très proche de la communauté juive
liégeoise elle la défend
et elle va raconter au prêtre catholique
que lors de ses voyages et bien il s'est
aperçue qu'au paradis il y avait des
musulmans et des Juifs ce qui est tout à
fait il recevable vous comprenez mais
c'est ces documents là je ne les ai pas
trouvé évidemment cette relation par
exemple je ne l'ai pas trouvé donc en
temps après dans le moine qui racontait
sa vie je l'ai trouvé dans le livre des
pieux qui est écrit par Judas gratisbon
qui est un rabbin qui vivait à l'époque
à cette époque là et qui raconte que
elle était elle très proche de la
communauté juive donc c'est à dire que
OUI pour écrire ce livre à la fois il
m'a fallu beaucoup me documenter à
partir des textes canoniques mais
essayez de voir autour aussi tout ce
qu'on racontait vous remercier un nombre
hallucinant de personnes parce que vous
avez dû lire énormément de décrit à son
propos alors
avez à son propos non sur le long mais
sur l'époque et notamment sur sur
la place des femmes et ça c'est
complètement hallucinant c'est à dire
que le point de départ c'est
Eve n'est n'ont pas à côté ce qui est la
traduction littérale exacte mais n'est
de la côte d'Adam
à partir de là il y a le péché originel
qui suit avec Eve dans le jardin avec
les clients qui offre la pomme etc en
français
ça coût faire à la femme un statut de
second plan tire de ça ça supériorité
c'est-à-dire que la place n'a aucune la
femme n'a aucune place dans cette
société elle est en permanence elle est
battue en permanence son mari a droit de
vie et de et de mort sur elle on
explique que au fond une femme est folle
une femme est versatile
une femme dérange une femme est une
sorcière
etc etc et elle comment dire va se lever
quoi contre ça elle est contre aussi
l'idée que les les nonnes au fond ce qui
régit les couvent de femmes ce sont des
hommes ce sont les moines qui ont mis ça
et ces femmes sont entourées de d'hommes
les jardiniers etc etc j'ai 218 elle dit
nous allons bouleverser l'ordre des
choses et trouver dans l'existence et
dans la religion la place qui nous
revient voilà c'est ça c'est-à-dire que
le le
ce qu'on reproche essentiellement à ces
femmes qu'on va appeler des femmes
errantes c'est à dire qu'ils vont se
promener de village en village pour
porter une bonne parole c'est que ces
femmes commentent les écritures et une
femme n'a pas le droit avec leur n'a pas
l'accès n'a pas le droit de lire les
écritures et de les commenter il n'y a
que des relig déjà à peine à peine mais
elle sait ce qu'elle fait et donc elle
appelle un soulèvement des femmes ça va
donner les femmes errantes et ça va
donner plus tard les béguines qui vont
se rassembler entre elles sans la
tutelle sans la tutelle des hommes mais
ce qui est grave évidemment c'est que
dans cette dans cette perspective de
femmes errante et de begins vous savez
on a on a reproché à l'église à juste
titre de devoir brûler les cathares pour
hérésie et on se dit à l'époque l'église
va recommencer avec les femmes parce que
l'Église a peur de la mystique féminine
elle a peur de la puissance des femmes
de la puissance des femmes et
1236 donc c'est à dire quelques années
après la mort de
1236 on brûle la première femme la
première béguine adélice à Cambrai en
tant que sorcière 1310 on en brûle une
seconde pour été Marguerite et avec le
livre qu'elle a qu'elle a écrit dans le
bûcher il y a elle et le livre ça va
amener à ce grand courant où on va
brûler des femmes et je vous rappelle
qu'en France uniquement en France du 14e
siècle au 17e siècle on a brûlé plus de
100.000 femmes mais ce qui m'intéressait
de décrire c'est qu'à cette époque là on
ne brûle pas les femmes
bon leur fait bien d'autres choses on
les intervenantes on les noix etc etc
donc ce qu'il faut quand même dire
excusez-moi c'est qu'elle avait quand
même des sacrés dons cette crise alors
sinon elle serait morte 25 fois enfin
elle aurait été tuée déjà depuis le
début de l'histoire il se trouve qu'elle
supporte des douleurs
insupportables elle a elle a vraiment
mal mais elle n'en a aucune c'est
qu'elle physique
et de la Meuse pendant des jours la
brûler voilà pas et c'est ça c'est quand
même ça sa force
incroyable et alors ben voilà ça aide
elle résiste à tout ça alors et en plus
ça c'est alors ça en revanche c'est
écrit dans le dans la le texte de du
moine quand un prix donc ça c'est pas
avant c'est vrai
on dit les hommes ont peur de la violer
et pourquoi parce que comme elle vole
les hommes soupçonne on se dit au fond
cette femme
son sexe doit être recouvert de plumes
d'oiseaux
et ça ça fait peur aux hommes
donc on ne va pas la violer parce que
les hommes ont peur sauf après il y en a
un qui va à la violer après bon bref
assez vite elles sont autour d'autres
femmes exactement des alliés des amis
qui sont elles aussi des femmes
mystiques qui ont elles aussi des
missions qui t'étonnent un peu quand
même aussi elle elle est un peu leader
j'ai l'impression elle se réfugier dans
une maison abandonnée c'est là qu'elles
vont acquérir une certaine indépendance
financière en exécutant certains travaux
et c'est là qu'elles se mettent à aller
dans les villages peu comme les apôtres
finalement
les blessés elle crée des hôpitaux
mais surtout ne m'intéresse surtout
elles vont sous le nez des possesseurs
de des gens qui ont l'argent et le
pouvoir parce que le le
grand péché à l'époque c'est l'avarice
et c'est tout ce qui est lié à l'argent
et donc elle va dans les villages elle
va partout et elle prône la
redistribution des richesses ce qui est
quelque chose de
d'inaudible à l'époque mais oui donc
elle a un côté un un côté Femen en fait
elle montre elle aussi quand elle est
sur son bûcher enfin il y a plein
d'histoires absolument incroyables mais
si vous voulez il y a pas de provocation
chez elle c'est à dire que
elle agit par rapport à ce qu'on le fait
subir elle va faire une sorte de force
d'amour une force de de de changement on
n'a pas de haine il y a aucune haine
chez elle
bien persécutée elle lui dit ben je
prendrai la moitié de tes douleurs quand
tu seras au pire gattoir oui parce que
son chemin c'est d'abord un chemin de
rédemption et ça c'est très important
bien entendu est-ce qu'elle voit les
morts-vivants qui sont là qui n'ont pas
compris qu'il fallait qu'ils montent et
elle aide aussi à ça elle aide les
vivants à mourir pour le passage et
l'aide les morts-vivants qui reviennent
sur terre accepter leur mort et à
remonter c'est vraiment son rôle
essentiel c'est un livre de foi et et
donc on ne peut pas écrire un livre
pareil sans croire à tout ça
m'a dit mais est-ce que tout ce que tu
racontes c'est vrai je dis oui
d'ailleurs le premier événement c'est
tout au début du livre c'est la page 3
c'est ce qu'on appelle elle ressuscite
des morts si on ne croit pas à cette
résurrection évidemment ce que mais ceci
dit on peut quand même lire le livre
indépendamment de de cela évidemment
mais c'est passionnant ça se lit d'une
femme moche d'élite d'une traite c'est
absolument passionnant c'est d'une
modernité incroyable c'est les
féministes enfin tout le monde le dit à
propos de ce livre mais je le répète ce
sont des féministes avant l'heure et
d'ailleurs elles imaginent de justement
repérer d'autres lieux abandonnés pour y
faire des maisons de femmes à l'abri
indépendant tout ça comme vous disiez
les les béguines voilà et après
malheureusement elle meurt avant de
mourir elle donne à chacune de ses elles
sont trois au total
les quatre points cardinaux et l'envoi
dans 4 points cardinaux ces femmes pour
aller prêcher la la sa parole en quelque
sorte et donc vos quatre prochains
romans ce sera la vie de ces gars de
femmes dans le prochain roman c'est
mingway ah oui vraiment et comment vous
l'avez trouvé elle et puis après on
arrête parce qu'on a dépassé le temps
écoutez
le livre dédié à sœur Anne mais oui qui
était une petite bénédictine que vous
connaissez
qui m'a parlé de ce c'est elle qui vous
en a parlé
passionnant on est emporté au delà du
temps pour une histoire en même temps
très moderne palpitante et vraiment qui
prend vraiment qui importe vous serez au
salon histoire de lire le 26 novembre
qui est un ou le 25 pardon ça sera le
samedi voilà il suffit de se renseigner
et donc l'année prochaine pour Emmy
ouais bien sûr génial merci Gérard à
très vite merci à tous de nous avoir
suivi à très bientôt
[Musique]